in the film your character you you take
back you reclaim the fanny pack or what
we call a bum bag one bag yes yeah yes I
do i do well it started with this
picture I have an infamous picture of me
in my 20s and I was just owning this
look I had a turtleneck
I had mom jeans on I was wearing a fat
goodbye I think we've got the picture
hell no there you are this was you being
serious yes no oh yes I think I'm cool
and are you aware that this has now
become a sort of fancy dress outfit
people do this they do this yeah as a
joke Seth Rogen was on the show yeah and
he showed us his version here Seth Rogen
as it
there's just a random man but very good
eye for detail see you've got the tissue
under the elbow which you have here it
goes but let me just give the audience
context is what that is the the what I
have my arm on was very dirty so I
thought I need a tissue please -
[Laughter]
beautiful and it's not just adults no
young fans are attracted to it as well
[Laughter]
actually some other people have done it
as well yeah check this out
[Applause]
with those guys three of you should
dress up and go out in London today yeah
the Peugeot is sterile
a lady called Beatrix on Twitter tweeted
sam neill to say hey are you a whip and
the first ad came over q okay am i yep
yep and I'm good I'm not going to show
any pain to Van Dam and I stood up and
then he takes his glasses off he turns
me out